one of the things that I have the
highest conviction over now as a
scientist is the concept of grace in
biology I grew up in kind of a Christian
environment and kind of hippy church and
Boulder and great people around and so I
had kind of a lexicon of kind of a
relatively open-minded church doctrine
and the word grace got through and
thrown around in this faith community
all the time and now I'm exposed to a
lot of people from all types of
spiritual backgrounds and going to the
Muslim or the Buddhists or their Jewish
communities you hear this word grace
with a different frequency but it's out
there in our lexicon
I think it can Moby maybe boast best be
defined now in my mind at least
scientifically which is heal faster than
you injury and that's what we see in the
soil and that's what I get to see my
clinic I see people who have abused
their bodies for decades and if they
just give a pause they do a couple of
short term fasts they give their gut a
break they give their immune system a
break they get away from chemicals they
start growing some of their own food and
make these simple little decisions and
suddenly decades of damage is reversed
in hours weeks months
that's grace at the cellular level and
there may be a better spiritual to
definition of it from a biology
standpoint I see grace as you're going
to make mistakes and you're gonna heal
fast or from them when you when you make
the change and that's what we see in the
soil and so these farmers who are making
the jump again we've seen a million
acres make this transition and so soil
health Academy is our partners in this
group and they're for phenomenal farmers
who really are have been cutting the
edge of this this no-till no-spray
effort and what we're seeing is that
within a single growing season you can
go from this dead monoculture of corn or
soybean to cover cropping with 16
different species and getting a no-till
environment you'll see the fungal
elements you'll see the micro micro rise
a in there the bacterial populations
returning the soil and you see
biodiversity returning in the form of
earthworms within a single growing
season of rest yeah it's the
environmental planetary version of what
you just explained in the human body
it's fascinating
yeah fast for just a moment stop doing
the damage for just a short bit
resiliency is amazing
it's amazing and it would have to be
there's a book recently out and I'm
gonna screw up the title I think it's
something like earth without humans or
something like this and it describes how
fast the ecosystem is gonna recover when
we disappear from government it
describes New York City two weeks
without humans and you see every element
of the the concrete infrastructure of
Manhattan disappearing under biology and
within two months and two years and you
see how fast life leaps out of this
planet and it has to be that way because
it's Mother Earth uh-huh that's how we
got here this finite planets been
exploding with life for millions of
millions of years before Homo sapiens
showed up we got to combat this problem
I mean one of the things that we talked
about last time that was so shocking for
me to hear was just the pervasiveness of
of chemical spraying so even if you are
an organic farmer or you are consumer
buying organic or you're trying to you
know live in a clean environment that
glyphosate and various other chemicals
are so pervasive they found their way
into our drinking water it's in the rain
water it's raining down onto these
organic farms so despite trying to
hermetically remove ourselves from this
problem it's it's still you know
something that we have to contend with
even when we're doing everything in our
power to avoid it I mean first of all
why is that why is glyphosate everywhere
it's the nature of the molecule itself
it's an amino acid backbone with a
phosphate group and and a carbon group
on the other end and you get this thing
called an organophosphate and
organophosphates in this form are
extremely water soluble 70% of Earth is
water and it turns out that 70% of your
body as water and so we've put into play
a chemical that is water-soluble
that can now travel through all levels
of the water ecosystems and so in the
evaporating water coming off the
Mississippi River as we collect some 80%
of all the roundup sprayed in our
country into a single water system
through the what runoff that happens
when we water or when the rain falls or
whatever it is we consolidate that into
the great muddy and I shouldn't be muddy
but it's carrying all of our topsoil in
it now because all of our topsoil is
dead and was routing away an amazing
estimate on that actually I just read
that eleven percent of our gdp is being
wasted every year in topsoil the amount
of monetary loss from our topsoil
washing away is equal to 11 percent of
GDP because it's so unhealthy that it
doesn't it here exactly
yeah there's no root structure to keep
it there there's no my mic right
mycorrhizae there's no mycelium there's
no fungal structure in the soil to keep
the topsoil where it needs to be and so
every time it rains the rain can't even
penetrate the soil which is ridiculous
it's so hard that the water when it
finally rains on your crop can't get
into the soil instead it takes the top
centimeter of your soil away and washes
it to the nearest gully and out into the
water system which of course ends up in
a Mississippi River and then into the
Delta and at the end of the Mississippi
River we now have a dead zone that's
larger than the state of Rhode Island
because there's so much herbicide
pesticide and chemical fertilizer in
that water and so we've got this huge
dead zone in the ocean right at the
mouth of the Mississippi and not a
single politician was talking about that
Delta founding that we can be this
myopic um so soil is disappearing all of
this is broken yes yes yes yes but I
still want to bring it back to the
simple reality as the the brokenness in
the system has to do with the isolation
of human relationship if we connect the
farmer back to the consumer and we cut
out the banks we cut out the farm bill
we cut out the big chemical industry
that's that's trying to educate them
incorrectly we have a cut on all those
players the amount of money we save is
extraordinary first of all but the
amount of money we can bring into those
lands is extraordinary so there's such a
huge economic incentive right now
for farmers to make this jump they just
need support for about three years to
make the transition because after three
to five years they can take crop yields
right now if they're under GMO crop they
can expect a yield maybe forty bucks an
acre after they subtract out all of
their inputs and everything else so
typical family farm you're growing maybe
300 acres of corn soybean some mix
thereof 300 acres times your 40 dollars
you're at a dismal annual income and to
achieve that you've woken up every
morning at 4 a.m. you go to sleep at 10
p.m. you cry yourself to sleep every
night your your relationship with your
wife is so stressed because she's
yelling that change has to happen
because the kids are sick she does have
money to pay the health bills can't fill
the pharmacy prescriptions dad's
chomping at you because you know you
must be doing something wrong so it's
not working you need to change and for
that you get your your dismal you know
which goes to just service the debt
service is the debt right and so then
you have to borrow money to buy the seed
to buy the fertilizers for your next
crop and you're back in the cycle again
and so this is the reality for so many
of these farms and you know I just have
to be amazed at the economic incentive
on the other side of this is these farms
and there's no more over million acres
that have made the transition back to
region AG over the last 15 years these
guys are seeing returns per acre of 500
to 900 dollars an acre from $40 40 oh my
god and so it's we want to believe that
there's some impossible way it's too
hard to get you know money for organic
food no it's so much more lucrative
these farmers they could be the most
lucrative generation of farmers in their
entire family if they can get to region
a ground and what you said earlier is
that to make that transition costs about
a hundred dollars per acre in order to
kind of help these people make that
switch yeah and and the hundred dollars
it doesn't even need to go to being a
safety net income entirely so the third
of it we see going to their education a
third of it we see going to consume
education and then a third of it we see
becoming a safety net income for them or
they not mind get paid but we say if you
were to fail because that's their fear
if I don't do what I've been doing the
last 15 or 20 years of chemicals my crop
next year is gonna fail and I'm gonna go
bankrupt and so we don't need to give
them an income necessarily but what we
can say is look you know we've now
raised enough private funds for you that
we can give you a safety net that says
if you're actually in this transition of
no-spray no-till and you happen to fail
one of those years we can get we'll meet
you at $40 an acre
right we'll meet you there you can't
drunk you you will not go down an income
that's what we need to do is create that
safety right right right that's safety
net I don't think is II mean have to be
tapped into because the farmers that are
making the transition are already seeing
improved yields year one of going back
to a non GMO seed